[Music]
are you still hungry
takes a lot of energy to summon my chief
what you made quite a great team now I'm
looking for Superfriends me neither you
keep on telling yourself
- the hell are you God is going to help
you say necessary the war for New York
is here
they haven't noticed everything not yet
so get your [ __ ] together we have time
to grab a drink
[Music]
let's go do something crazy I only went
back there's no karate
Danny but it oh I can see you form upon
here I promise you it's temporary if I
can help it
[Applause]
[Music]
so call immediate it's kind of cool
everybody new defenders trailer this
might actually wind up being the last
one but what's going to happen is I'll
explain my video schedule for the
episodes when it drops next week so if
you didn't know it's dropping on Friday
but you should probably start watching
it Thursday night at midnight so if you
can swing it I recommend you do that but
I love the way they cut this trailer
it's meant to be a little more humorous
like they had this really awesome
chemistry on-screen together it'll talk
a little bit more about how they come
together when I post my first review
video later this week it'll be non
spoilery but they do dedicate a lot of
time to try and blending the tone of all
the characters so that even though the
show carries a lot of the stuff that's
come before with it like you begin with
moments with each of the characters
separately so you sort of refresh your
memory about what's going on in their
own individual universes and then a
couple big WTF moments happen they start
clashing and they come together so when
they're in this restaurant sizing each
other up it's actually the first time
that they all come together watching
Danny ran stuff his face but then stick
comes along and explains what's actually
going on like look this is the war for
New York then the hand gets the drop on
them you see Alexandre sort of tell them
to back off like now is your last chance
this isn't going to end well for you
you even see Elektra come in at this
point - she's still wearing that big
trench coat of hers but then they start
jumping around in time like you have
this training moment where dick is
trying to explain everything to them
they're interrogating this person at the
end of the trailer Luke 8 is like yeah I
guess you know Daredevils pretty cool he
had that billy clubs pretty neat and you
get a couple really good shots of how
funny and awesome it is to watch them
take people down like they have a couple
different shots as they cut together of
this big hallway fight so like everybody
has their daredevil hallway fight in
like the fourth or fifth episode of each
of the series so of course think of the
epic hallway fight that they have to
have in defenders now that they're all
together so if you slow the trailer down
they actually cut it a little bit
weirdly like they jump around in time
during this individual scene so you have
Luke Cage crashing through the side of
the hallway like he literally rammed
some dude through the wall here as Matt
is walking down punching someone like he
normally would Jessica Jones throwing
people around iron fists going crazy and
in most of these shots you have Elektra
just casually walking up behind them so
I'm guessing because the daredevil isn't
turning around freaking out he doesn't
know what her status is at this point
and she's still working for Alexandra
this shot here looks like it's from
later in that scene where Elektra is
either getting ready to try and kill
Matt or iron fist and he just
obliterated her sword with his Chi the
really cool thing about this too is that
iron fist they sort of upgrade his power
levels through this series but there's
still going to be a lot of ground to
cover when they get to iron fist season
two but remember how Madame Gao also
kind of understands how to harness her
Chi not to the level that Iron Fist can
but you see them underground here like
in this underground pit area that we saw
during daredevil season two going up
against the hand and Luke Cage says
light him up and he just unleashes the
iron fist and just blows them all back
she's got her fists extended here so
I'll be interested to see what kind of
badass move she has because they've been
hyping Madame Gao up for a long time and
if she's sort of the underdog to
Alexandra it makes you wonder what's
going on with her like what kind of
crazy power does she have as of right
now it sounds like she's an original
character not from the comics but that
could always change they could always
reveal her as someone else but I'm not
expecting her to wind up being the demon
that they worshipped because that's
supposed to be who black sky is like the
people that harness the energy of the
demon become conduits for him to come
back into this plane of existence the
effects actually look really good it
looks like they really did spend the
extra money on this I love the way that
Luke cages arm gives off sparks when
Elektra tries to slash him you even get
a little bit of a Heroes for Hire moment
where Iron Fist is hiding behind him
here using them as a human shield
but when episodes drop you guys will see
like they're still working up to Heroes
for Hire stuff they don't genuinely get
any like really big moments like that
because they're just coming together for
the first time but you do feel that
chemistry so you will wonder after this
why don't they just do a Heroes for Hire
series and I have a couple theories for
why that is but mostly I think it's just
contractual on Netflix's end and for
those of you asking a lot of people have
been messaging me about this Disney
Marvel Netflix deal that's supposedly
going away soon the big thing that
happened recently is the Disney
announced that it was going to develop
its own streaming service and it was
going to put all of its content
there so it was taking it off of Netflix
even if that does wind up happening
that doesn't include Marvel and Netflix
is deal for these TV shows Netflix owns
the rights to those like they're
literally paying for these to happen
it's not like they're Licensing content
from Marvel it's just like Star Wars
movies the Marvel movies the stuff that
Netflix bias to redistribute Punisher
would still be okay to and I know we
haven't seen any new trailers for that
yet but that's really just because
they're mostly pushing defenders right
now like they'll be hitting it pretty
hard next week with this stuff but I
would expect that within the next couple
weeks after people have a chance to
watch defenders then they'll start
teasing out more punisher stuff i know
you all want to know if Punishers part
of defenders you have to remember that
when they were filming this TV series
they were also filming the punisher TV
series too so it was just a question of
scheduling so just don't expect Punisher
to show up in high five everybody every
single episode but he's still part of
this universe so they'll probably a
couple really interesting surprises
later in the series part of the fun of
this series is seeing all the weird
pairings my favorite new pairing of
characters that you haven't seen
together before is Jessica Jones and
daredevil you've seen some of their
earliest scenes in the trailer where he
just busts in and tries to help her get
out of prison you have interrupted a
citywide investigation
you stole evidence from my crime scene
and you got my one lead killed I was
trying to help him but you didn't just
stop talking how the hell are you
My name is Matthew Murdock I'm her
attorney so once you do get a chance to
see the first couple of episodes let me
know in the comments who's your favorite
new pairing because you have all these
characters sometimes there's just a
couple of them on-screen together and
everybody wants to see some Heroes for
Hire at some point they're meeting on
screen is really awesome
for a whole different reason if you were
kind of bummed out by Iron Fist and not
really happy about the character you
will love the first time that they meet
on screen it's hilarious
they have been doing a lot of interviews
so if you guys want me to post some of
their interview videos they said some
interesting stuff so leave all your
bonus video requests in the comments
below be sure to subscribe to get
everything and there will be a new
Marvel giveaway when I start posting
episode videos
so my first non-spoilery review will
post next week maybe by like Wednesday
so while you wait for all that you can
click here for more defenders and you
can click here for my infinity war
trailer video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
you